eine neue studie erstaunt jetzt sogar
experten demnach könnten nämlich könnte
die sterblichkeitsrate bei corona
weitaus geringer liegen als bisher
angenommen die sterberate liegt hier bei
0 27 also auf 1000 infizierte gerechnet
bedeutet dass es sterben im schnitt 27
personen
ja das ist weit weniger als bisher
angenommen aber man muss auch sagen das
ist kein abschließendes fazit die studie
ist auch unter wissenschaftlern durchaus
umstritten und das ergebnis dieser
studie möchte ich jetzt besprechen mit
philipp potthoff der hier bei mir im
studio zu gast ist aus unserem
politikressort er erst mal sind es ja
gute nachrichten die wie yao hat diese
studie veröffentlicht sie kommt von der
universität stanford und man könnte
annehmen dass die sterblichkeit weit
geringer liegt als bisher angenommen
warum können wir uns denn nicht nur
freuen also zunächst ja die studie wurde
von der whu veröffentlicht und der
professor ist tatsächlich auch ein sehr
renommierter fachmann auch wenn er sich
klar als gegner das lockt downs bislang
ausgesprochen hat wie du gesagt hast die
studie kommt zu dem ergebnis dass die
sterblichkeit unter gewohnter
infizierten deutlich niedriger als
angenommen
ursprünglich ging man ja von über drei
prozent aus anhand der daten die man aus
china hatte er kommt jetzt auf 0,27
prozent bislang ist das so dass experten
wie christian drosten für deutschland
eine sterblichkeit von circa einem
prozent erwarten
und das ist auch ganz wichtig es gibt
nicht die eine cola sterblichkeit
sondern das hängt sehr davon ab wer sich
infiziert und das hängt in deutschland
haben wir nochmal eine ältere
gesellschaft als beispielsweise in
afrika das heißt nur wenn sich weil in
afrika als so viele junge menschen gibt
wenn die sich anstecken im sterben davon
nicht so viele davon
da können wir nicht direkte rückschlüsse
für deutschland ziehen
aber und das muss man sagen ist das
dennoch ein realistischer blick auf die
sterblichkeit als wenn wir uns nur die
sogenannte fall sterblichkeit anschauen
das heißt wie viele personen von den
bekannten infizierten dies hier in
deutschland gibt es im gestorben wenn
man sich dann die aktuellen zahlen
anschaut da kommt man auf 2,7 prozent
was man wahnsinnig hohe stern
möglichkeit wäre also nicht 0,27 sondern
2,7 prozent ja das ist das zehnfache
aber da geht es nur darum wie viele
menschen gestorben sind von jenen von
dem man wusste dass sie sich infiziert
hatten
und das ist natürlich eine deutlich
höhere zahl die ware sterblichkeit ist
deutlich niedriger was bedeutet das
jetzt für uns in einfachen worten
bedeutet dass das ist vielleicht doch
nicht so gefährlich ist wie angenommen
oder ist das einfach eine weitere zeit
die fakten bleiben aber gleich ist es
ein virus das ist gefährlich menschen
sterben daran
das ist bleibt die tatsache dass es
gefährlich ist das gefährlichste an dem
virus ist jedoch nicht die sterblichkeit
sondern das gefährlichste ist die
mögliche überlastung der krankenhäuser
weil das virus sich sehr schnell
verbreitet weil es dagegen noch keine
erprobte behandlung gibt und auch keinen
impfstoff
aber allein von der sterblichkeit muss
man sagen haben sich die erwartungen
etwas
naja sind wir können wir jetzt etwas
optimistischer sein als im vergleich zum
frühjahr da haben uns die ersten daten
aus china gezeigt dass eventuell über
drei prozent sterben können experten
haben modellrechnungen angestellt mit
millionen toten in einzelnen ländern so
schlimm ist es zum glück nicht gekommen
das muss man sagen also sprich
eigentlich eine gute nachricht weiterhin
spielt aber das alter und auch der ort
wo die menschen wo die erkrankten leben
eine große rolle
deswegen pauschale aussagen sind so
eigentlich nicht möglich
philipp peter vielen herzlichen dank für
deinen besuch im studio
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren